welcome back to las vegas now there's a
local mother who wants to warn other
parents about a rare copic complications
kids can endure thanks to intermountain
healthcare the sponsors of this segment
families facing this challenge have the
care that they need
covet 19 can turn a regular health
condition into a rare one he is a bright
young boy he's very smart
athletic he runs around all day but
as for right now he came
you know due to
what happened to him with his kobe 19
turned into mifc with the help of
intermountain healthcare shirella ruffin
mother of seven-year-old zaire is on a
mission to warn other families of this
covic complication misc stands for
multi-system inflammatory syndrome in
children associated with covid19 dr
trong a pediatric cardiologist says misc
is something she has seen since the
start of the pandemic and is one of the
most extreme ways kids can be impacted
by covid most common symptoms that we
see are gastrointestinal symptoms we
also commonly see something called
mucocutaneous changes meaning a rash
red eyes
sometimes kids can have swollen hands
as well
things that gets kids in most trouble
with misc is that it can affect the
heart namely it can affect the squeeze
of the heart and then as i mentioned
kids can present in shock zaire was
unusually weak and sleepy as well after
several doctors opinions and still so
much uncertainty shirella finally got
answers so we called 9-1-1 and from
9-1-1 we went to umc hospital and we
never left from there
and that's when it all came out that he
had
cobit it turned into misc
and
they can't um determine when he had to
cope it they don't really know but they
know that he had it
yeah the antibodies zaire's condition
became worse but his family's hope
became greater when introduced to
intermountain primary children's
hospital in salt lake city utah and i
thank god that that happened because
today he wouldn't be here dr chong who
is with the primary children's hospital
says zaire's case was one of the most
severe they've ever seen and in order to
save his life he needed to be on an ecmo
machine which is extracorporeal membrane
oxygenation meaning that his body was so
sick that his heart was not squeezing
well
and
that
sort of
apparatus helps to
maintain organ perfusion because he was
so sick according to various studies
less than four percent of kids with misc
have actually needed the ecmo machine so
in zaire's case he became a survivor
and a legend he was the first kid that
ever
flew with an echo
you know now they know that it works and
they can fly and save other kids life
not all children's hospitals have ecmos
so with their team their resources and
studies on misc the intermountain
primary children's hospital is at the
forefront of understanding treating and
managing this condition the biggest
thing with them is the love and support
that they they give people and that
shirella is accepting donations for
zaire's care and praise he can get back
on the dance floor and the basketball
court soon she wants to leave other
parents with this message about misc a
lot of people say my kid was healthy my
kid was healthy
your kid can be healthy and
it can still take over
your kid life that's how strong it is
continued prayers for their family thank
you to intermountain healthcare for
sponsoring this segment for more
information
visit
intermountainhealthcare.org
nevada we'll be right back